was uns besonders markt müssen wir
offensiv präzise und schnell meine
aufgabe ist es dabei das ist so schnell
wie möglich die feier unterstützung egal
ob vom boden boden oder luft boden
dorthin bringen wo es da kann man an
[Musik]
termin mit ihnen dann noch das flugzeug
außer springen oder von 3000 meter hohen
berg rhein und es kein problem das ist
eigentlich schuld doppel
[Musik]
motte schnell und professionell
hochdynamisch ich weiß dass er es und
wie war es das erst über euch selber
nicht sagen würde aber ich darf er
liefert knapp genug und nah genug dran
und es zu wissen
danke nochmal für einen tollen tag mit
kaffee und danke für ihr angebot